bonjour mesdames
et messieurs soyez les bienvenus pour
cette seconde table ronde de notre
matinée en ce qui nous concerne
puisqu'on a fait l'océan Indien et
Pacifique un peu plus tôt pour tenir
compte des contraintes horaires de vos
collègues et puis des vôtres pour le
coup maintenant et merci de votre
disponibilité je vous propose
pour commencer de puisque vous avez été
destinataire d'un questionnaire qui qui
visait à préparer cette audition on va
on va traiter cette audition par bloc
moi je vais faire toute la partie sur le
bilan en fait de la situation actuelle
de votre point de vue et puis
j'essaierai le soin à ma cour rapporteur
michigeac de d'aller sur la partie
plutôt d'évolution de ce de ce sujet
avec les différentes questions qui
peuvent évidemment se poser sur la
partie du bilan de l'organisation
institutionnelle
j'aurais bien aimé vous entendre
successivement dans l'ordre et puis je
vous dirai l'ordre dans lequel en fait
on va on va vous donner la parole
déjà premièrement de vous entendre sur
le bilan que vous faites de
l'organisation institutionnelle des
territoires au regard au regard des
perspectives de développement économique
je pense que c'est un lien très fort et
c'est pour ça que nous avons tenu à vous
auditionner autant le cadre de nos
travaux
et puis le premier bloc qui m'intéresse
dans ce cadre là de ce bilan c'est
notamment les exemples que vous pourriez
avoir soit d'action ou de stratégie qui
n'aurait pas pu être mise en place ou
qui aurait été entravés ont raison de
l'inaptation des normes à vos
territoires respectifs et on sait que
les réalités sont différentes d'un
territoire à l'autre c'est aussi
l'intérêt de de vous avoir autour de la
table et lorsque c'est énorme doivent
être adaptées aux réalités de vos
territoires qu'elles devraient être
selon vous l'autorité la plus pertinente
pour que cette adaptation arrive et
enfin sur cette première partie sur les
compétences adaptations des normes dans
le cadre de l'élaboration des différents
tests législatifs et même réglementaires
si on prend la partie décrétale et de
vous associer parfois ou pas du tout
pour émettre des avis ou des
recommandations sur des évolutions de
législatives on sait que souvent le
gouvernement consulte dans un temps très
contraint les collectivités conc et on
s'interroge de savoir si le monde
socio-économique lui est également saisi
ou si vous ne figurez pas encore pour
l'instant sur le radar de ce type de
consultation voilà donc pour commencer
ce que je vous propose je vous donne
l'ordre et puis après je vous redonne la
parole on va commencer par la Guyane
ensuite Saint-Martin Guadeloupe puis
Martinique donc je vais laisser la
parole à la présidente de la commission
aménagement du territoire et numérique
et de la commission transport de la CCI
Guyane madame Joël Prevost moderne
madame vous avez la parole
si vous m'entendez bien évidemment je ne
vous vois pas l'écran mais on vous voit
connecter
pour pour la Guyane Philippe cambril
directeur général madame Prévost Madère
et bien et bien en ligne par contre des
fonctions de voix d'accord prenez le
relais il y a aucune difficulté il y a
aucune difficulté
donc pour la Guyane sur la partie
bilan de l'organisation institutionnelle
nos constats et nos remarques sont les
suivantes
une multiplication alors nous constatons
nous une multiplication des appels à
projets et le recours des appels à
projets ça se traduit finalement par
une tentative de déclinaison
systématique d'orientation et priorité
nationale sur le plan du sur le plan
local et c'est peut-être là qu'on a le
plus de difficultés finalement à ce à ce
à se positionner du fait de parfois le
décalage entre les objectifs nationaux
et la situation réelle du terrain en ce
qui concerne
l'adaptation des normes
notre notre préoccupation c'est quand
même de souligner que parfois la norme
poursuit un objectif qui est pertinent
pour une situation je dirais standard
moyenne mais qui peut être totalement
contradictoire à la situation du terrain
et que parfois également le territoire
poursuit un objectif une stratégie de
développement
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas au même
niveau de maturation que que d'autres et
que donc les objectifs poursuivis par
une norme devrait pouvoir être par
moment écarté ou en tout cas
retenu en ce qui concerne l'adaptation
des normes et nous sommes que c'est
assez au niveau local de
s'en charger le tout bien sûr on peut
construction avec l'État mais avec un
état local qui serait investi d'un réel
pouvoir de négociation aujourd'hui trop
souvent on constate dans les
processus de contractualisation des
politiques publiques les marges de
manœuvre de l'État local sont
relativement restreintes les crédits
sont extrêmement séchés et on n'est pas
sur de la contractualisation
au regard des priorités du territoire
mais bien sûr comment on peut au mieux
décliner les priorités qui sont sur la
feuille de route du préfet
voilà en ce qui concerne la consultation
lors des phases d'élaboration
il nous apparaît que c'est uniquement
des consultations des parlementaires que
ce soit le Sénat ou l'Assemblée
nationale mais très rarement à d'autres
à d'autres niveaux
voilà pour la Guyane merci merci cher
Monsieur maintenant nous passons à
Saint-Martin je pense que le directeur
général monsieur bataille doit être
connecté et vous avez la parole
oui bonjour
La cessé de Saint-Martin dans un
contexte encore un peu particulier au
sein des Outre-mer puisque
Chambre territoriale d'une collectivité
Saint-Martin ça fait particulière 74
donc une petite un peu moins de 15 ans
de d'expérience de ce nouveau statut
d'un point de vue institutionnel
l'exercice des compétences de la
collectivité
c'est pas toujours accompagné des
transferts de moyens mais ça ça a été
d'ailleurs ce qui est remarquable pour
l'économie locale c'est que finalement
les chefs d'entreprise ou les
groupements sociaux professionnels et la
CCI en particulier du s'adapter à ce
changement institutionnel on a inventé
une nouvelle façon de
de faire du développement avec une CCI
territoriale qui parle à la fois avec sa
collectivité et qui parle aussi avec les
services de l'État depuis notamment
depuis 2017 le cyclonira mais aussi
progressivement et à travers la crise
covid par exemple les services de l'État
se sont progressivement renforcés avec
des unités territoriales dans les
domaines de
fois de l'entreprise de la concurrence
aussi de la formation et donc la
représentation socio-professionnelle
parle
aussi bien avec sa collectivité qu'avec
qu'avec les services de l'État
l'ingénierie de l'État est présente la
collectivité se renforce et l'exercice
des compétences se fait se fait plutôt
manière progressive pour nous il est pas
question de renoncer à certaines
compétences mais il n'est pas non plus
question dans le monde dans
l'intégrer d'autres puisque puisqu'on
est encore voilà presque 15 ans après en
train de de consolider en termes de
ressources humaines en termes de
financement et et d'autres d'autres
types de Dolan
le partage des compétences pour nous ici
il est il est très clair le sujet des
normes il a été évoqué vous savez qu'on
a une frontière ouverte avec le pays
Saint-Martin c'est le matin qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas l'Europe qui n'est pas
un espace vraiment un pays tiers on va
dire à l'Union européenne
mais voilà frontière ouverte livre
circulation des marchandises et des
biens libre circulation des travailleurs
aussi à ce qui peut poser parfois de
quelques sujets de déjà de commerce
international mais aussi de normes on
parle de normes de construction par
exemple vous savez que Saint-Martin est
en reconstruction depuis depuis 5 ans et
la matière première du ciment par
exemple à proposer quelques difficultés
en termes de disponibilité et de
livraison et donc on s'est posé des
questions d'adaptation des normes de
construction c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres pour pour accélérer ce
processus un autre exemple que je peux
citer qui est directement lié aux
activités de la CCI actuellement c'est
comment on coordonne des filières
métiers par exemple
le secteur de la pêche professionnelle
la
pareil peut-être une difficulté de
lisibilité pour la collectivité
territoriale de ce qu'elle peut faire de
ce qu'elle doit faire en cette matière
et on se on se trouve confronté voilà à
une nécessité d'innovation réglementaire
et peut-être législatif à terme pour
pouvoir organiser cette filière de la
même manière qu'elle est organisée dans
d'autres territoires de
de la France
sur sur les sujets voilà bon
accompagnant de l'État je l'ai dit ça se
passe plutôt pas mal nous on travaille
avec beaucoup de on travaille beaucoup
en groupe de travail à la fois avec les
services de l'État la collectivité et
l'ensemble de la représentation
socio-professionnelle
bon la CCI je l'ai dit est un la CCI de
Saint-Martin
est un étudié donc qui est territorial
et qui a l'ensemble des compétences de
chambre de métier aussi et de
chandeliculture en plus de celle des
chambres de commerce
il n'y a pas eu d'incertitude
particulière concernant le nouveau
statut l'évolution institutionnelle 74
ainsi 74 pendant la Constitution par
contre ce qu'on a relevé c'est que
pendant les débats préparatoires
peut-être la le secteur privé le secteur
économique n'a pas toujours été
suffisamment
consulté et voilà depuis une quinzaine
d'années comme je vous disais on
travaille de manière itérative avec
l'ensemble des acteurs pour consolider
ça ça n'a pas eu on va dire boost je
pense que ça a été dit dans les propos
introductifs on se développe pas plus
qu'une qu'une
économie qui est dans une collectivité
dans un statut un peu plus traditionnel
pour autant la dynamique la dynamique
économique se met en place qu'on a
peut-être pu noter à des dépenses
sociales
probablement augmenter et
une nécessité en fait d'avoir un
atterrissage
pour avoir des politiques économiques
fiscales vous savez que la fiscalité est
une compétence de la collectivité
territoriale de Saint-Martin et qui doit
se régler pour donner tout le tout le
tous les faits multiplicateurs et tous
les faits entraînant d'une fiscalité
économique sur sur notre territoire
et enfin sur les questions on va dire
progresser sur notre statut
au niveau de l'Europe on reste région
ultra périphérique le débat pays
territoire d'outre-mer reste ouvert
depuis un certain temps mais pour autant
il n'a pas il y a pas d'indices si vous
voulez pour qu'on puisse aller plus loin
dans ce dans ce processus comme l'on
fait par exemple nos voisins de
Saint-Barthélemy
voilà merci
merci monsieur je propose maintenant de
partir
pas très très loin en Guadeloupe et
c'est Monsieur Collet qui est le
président qui a la parole
bonjour à tous
bonjour mesdames et messieurs
je voudrais pas être redondant sur ce
qu'a dit ce qu'on dit les collègues
précédents parce que je constate que au
final il n'y a pas de grandes
différences en fonction des
différents statuts des collectivités et
je vais essayer de me concentrer sur
quelques questions qui sont en addition
de ce qui a été dit
sur les compétences et l'adaptation des
normes
qu'on peut dire c'est que il y a pas
véritablement de capacité d'adaptation
des normes et donc on se retrouve à
certains moments
bloqué par l'incapacité de l'adaptation
de nos normes par rapport à
des situations environnement de
l'environnement proche géographique
c'est à dire
tout ce qui se passe autour de nous et
dont on aurait pu profiter mais qui du
coup n'est pas possible parce qu'on est
dans des normes je dirais plutôt
européenne
l'organisation des institutions alors
l'enchanteur autrement de compétences
ça existe vraiment surtout maintenant
avec des agglomérations qui ont une
compétence
économique donc du coup on se retrouve
avec pour ceux qui nous concernent la
Région Guadeloupe qui a la compétence
économique
globale sur le territoire et avec
d'autres communautés d'agglomérations
qui elles sont sectorisées
géographiquement et qui à mon sens cette
superposition nous a plutôt compliqué la
tâche autre chose
d'autant que chacun veut marquer ton
territoire donc c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas si ça le rôle de
l'accompagnement de l'État
qui nous concerne ça se passe très bien
j'ai envie de dire c'est pas tant dans
le fait que c'est ça soit cadré huilé ça
vient beaucoup des relations que peuvent
avoir le président de champ avec le
préfet et les différences
administrations entre elles font que les
choses se passent bien et que au final
les chambres sont
roues jouent le rôle qu'elle doit jouer
pour l'État c'est à dire d'un
établissement public qui peut amener
des précisions de la communication
dispenser les informations de l'État
mais en tout état de cause
le préfet n'est pas n'a pas les
compétences selon moi d'adapter ou de
déroger aux règles localement
ou tout à moins si les as c'est assez
superficiel
voilà je vais pas en rajouter plus à
leur nouveau
c'est on a ces questions qui sont posées
sur l'évolution institutionnelle de
façon assez récurrente à peu près toutes
les décennies par revient
ont été amenés à se prononcer de façon
différenciée selon les territoires et on
en est là on en est aujourd'hui voilà
j'ai terminé
merci monsieur le Président propose
maintenant de passer à la Martinique je
crois que Monsieur Jacques
est en ligne me semble-t-il si c'est le
cas vous avez la parole
c'est le président
votre micro est coupé
bonjour
cher collègue
sur le premier le premier item
concernant le bilan de réalisation
institutionnel ce que nous
pouvons dire à la Martinique c'est que
le rôle
la responsabilité développement
économique et confiée à la CTM de pose
pas le problème en soi toutefois on
regrette l'absence de co-construction
entre l'État la collectivité et les
acteurs socio-économiques et de
comprendre le bus c'est plus une
question d'homme que de que
d’institutions institutionnelle donc
comme le disait Patrick vient collé en
fonction des relations vous pouvez avoir
avec les présidents des collectivités ou
le préfet le rôle des chambres est plus
ou moins accru et plus ou moins
important
s'agissant de la question des normes oui
je crois qu'il y a un travail à faire
sur les sur les évolution l'adaptation
des normes pour faire en sorte que nous
soyons mieux intégrés à notre
environnement
géographique cordiale
il y a un travail qui commençait
notamment
sur les normes de constructions et de
matériaux de construction qui nous
permettraient d'avoir accès à des à des
produits
de la Caraïbe notamment ou l'Amérique
latine là aussi la question que vous
posez de savoir si
il appartient à l'État ou la
collectivité de gérer l'adaptation des
langues nous pensons nous à la Chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de Martinique
que sans qu'il n'y aura pas d'organismes
scientificateur local il vaut mieux que
la compétence de l'adaptation reste à
l'état
on reste ouvert à la station locale à
condition qu'il y ait sur place
les organismes certificateurs
indépendants c'est un point qui nous
paraît qui nous paraît essentiel et
enfin sur les consultations nous sommes
très très rarement consultés extrêmement
contraints
les mesures qui sont prises ou les
consultations de l'État la collectivité
ou la collectivité sur ses propres
décisions nous sommes acteurs économique
très rarement consultés voilà je vais
pas rajouter à ce que à ce que mes
collègues ont dit puisque nous
partageons globalement l'approche sur le
bilan des organisations
institutionnelles dans nos territoires
respectifs
merci monsieur le Président on va
repartir maintenant sur sur les
questions telles qu'elles s'enchaînent
et moi je serai intéressé à vous
entendre sur la partie état alors
certains d'entre vous l'ont déjà évoqué
on va repartir à la CCI de la Guyane sur
les moyens de l'État dans vos
territoires respectifs au niveau de la
déconcentration est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est moyen sont adaptés à votre
contexte local est-ce qu'il faut par
exemple assouplir les conditions dans
lesquelles le préfet peut déroger tels
que c'est prévu et adapter les règles à
votre territoire respectifs au regard
notamment un toujours en lien avec le
développement économique et vos champs
de vos champs d'intervention respectifs
oui donc pour la Guyane je
confirme finalement que le préfet a des
pouvoirs que mais qui sont qui sont
malheureusement
plutôt les pouvoirs sur le papier que
les pouvoirs des pouvoirs réels
nous il nous apparaît que il y a
un fléchage donc je le dis tout à
l'heure important
des crédits que le pouvoir du préfet
ne sera fort que s'il a également la
capacité
également la capacité de
d'orienter très fortement les décisions
des services extérieurs ou le
positionnement des services extérieurs
de l'État ce qu'on a constaté c'est que
les réformes successives des services
extérieurs je pense regroupement par
exemple enfin au passage des DDE en deal
et puis des DA en DGTM et on regroupé
les services extérieurs avec des des
cultures d'entreprises assez différentes
de se regroupement finalement arrive à
produire un peu de confusion et que on
sent pas le préfet en capacité d'avoir
toutes les marges de manœuvre pour
mettre de l'ordre et faire en sorte que
les services de l'État parlent d'une
seule voie sur un seul
sur sur un même projet
voilà donc encore une fois au niveau ça
reprend un thème de monter en fin de mon
propos précédent au niveau de la mise en
oeuvre notre sujet c'est vraiment qu'on
se rattache à un projet de développement
partager et que les capacités de
négociation du préfet tiennent compte
des orientations et de la stratégie du
local donc le sujet c'est aussi un sujet
de l'attitude du préfet et des capacités
du préfet à faire remonter finalement
les les grands axes de ce modèle de
développement et donc de pouvoir déroger
en fonction de ces sujets là je je vous
dis par exemple
la Guyane vous savez est un pays avec un
très fort un territoire avec un très
fort taux de croissance démographique
essentiellement dû à la volumes
d'immigration et à la à la rapidité de
cette immigration donc un pays en totale
construction et on se rend bien compte
que sur ce pays là qui a besoin de
ressources et qui besoin d'espace
s'interdire d'aller faire des recherches
d'hydrocarbure alors que tous nos
voisins prouvent du des du pétrole y
compris en grandes proximité avec la
Guyane sont des choses qui nous nous
paraissent nous paraissent difficiles de
la même façon quand on a une croissance
démographique énorme et qu'il nous faut
construire toute la réglementation de
limitation de consommation d'espace qui
s'applique à la Guyane alors que le pays
est en train de construction et en
pleine expansion nous paraît difficile à
à mettre en oeuvre et puis quand on
rentre dans le détail on se rend compte
que bien là les télés d'instruction
d'une opération pour produire du
foncière vocation économique peuvent
être extrêmement long et il est parfois
regrettable constater que il y a bien
une volonté préfectorale et de certains
services de
d'aboutir et de produire l'opération
mais on a
des blocages ou des oui c'est ça des
blocages parfois insurmontables on
n'arrive pas à raccourcir les délais
d'instruction on n'arrive pas à voir les
réponses en temps et en heure on
n'arrive pas à coordonner l'action de
tous les partenaires donc il y a une
question de contenu il y a une question
de méthode et il y a une question
probablement d'état d'esprit je crois
qu'il faut qu'on arrive pour pour être
plus efficace à un fonctionnement en
mode projet entre les services de l'État
des collectivités en associant les
champs de consulaires et notamment la
Chambre de commerce
merci beaucoup monsieur bataille à
Saint-Martin
de plus en plus intégré nos
interlocuteurs sont présentés ici c'est
des unités territoriales
des différentes directions qui peuvent
se trouver en Guadeloupe celle de la
direction des entreprises nous on parle
aussi avec la direction de la mer et
notre caractère consulaire aussi avec la
direction de l'alimentation et de la
forêt on participe à des groupes de
travail qui permettent de construire ou
de
co-construire la déclinaison des
politiques publiques en matière
développement économique sur le
territoire de la collectivité
Saint-Martin la collectivité est
elle-même associée à ces assez travaux
je le disais dans dans nos échanges
préalables avec les frères de des
collègues de l'Association des sociétés
d'outre-mer avant il y a quelques années
encore
la société était peut-être la dernière
consulter dans ces dans ces groupes
aujourd'hui on est les parmi parmi les
premiers invités à travailler et à
construire même ses groupes de travail
en partenariat avec avec les services de
l'État et un dernier exemple en date en
plus de nos rapports bien sûr
obligatoires avec le contrôle de
l'égalité et
d'autres dans le cas du service public
de l'emploi on a développé là on
développe actuellement en observatoire
de
est-ce qu'il va permettre de
rationaliser
cette activité non seulement du côté des
acheteurs je le répète on est encore
dans un contexte de
restructuration et de reconstruction de
nos infrastructures et puis aussi du
côté des offres du côté des entreprises
pour que la commande publique soit la
plus fine possible et la plus inclusive
possible voilà c'est un des exemples
concrets de travail que nous on arrive à
à mettre en place avec avec les services
de l'État un préfet qui est de plus en
plus à l'écoute du secteur privé et du
secteur
X qui s'appuie sur notre connaissance de
de terrain et sur notre position voilà
un peu un peu engrenage ou un peu
cheville entre le monde politique
et puis les et puis les entreprises
le secteur confondu
merci président
de la CCI de Guadeloupe
vous avez la parole merci
pour répondre à cette question
quelle est la capacité du pouvoir
finalement normatif local
et l'adaptation des normes et est-ce
qu'on doit aller plus loin bon je
constate que de d'année en année
des collectivités demandent la capacité
de gérer un certain nombre de domaines
dans la petite expérimental
pour nous en ce qui concerne les CCI
est représentant le monde de
l'entreprise
nous on a envie de dire que
il faudrait pouvoir adapter les normes
sur ce qui constitue un véritable frais
au développement économique
vu de l'état centralisé les normes
toutes centralisées qui donnent une
cohérence bien sûr
à l'État dans le cadre du droit commun
avec une capacité de pouvoir selon les
perspectives les développements
économiques adaptés localement
et qui sortent finalement un pouvoir
administratif de l'état
où chacun garde ses prérogatives je vais
prendre quelques exemples
bon nous sommes des petites îles donc
une grosse partie du territoire et de et
de son de sa capacité
de développement économique se retrouve
proche du rivage marin
que ce soit en mer ou très proche et de
plus en plus on s'en rend compte que
développer économiquement tout ce qui
est en rivage devient extrêmement
compliqué avec toutes les lois alors là
c'est carrément les lois et avec une
faible capacité d'adaptation des normes
par le préfet
on se la dirigé par l'ADL et au final
applique de façon extrêmement ferme
tout tout ce qui est contrainte et
obligations
pour donner encore un exemple plus
précis la vitesse où ça va on peut
considérer que le développement
économique
d'hébergement proche du littoral va
devenir totalement illusoire alors ça
pose quand même un problème très sérieux
puisque ça dépendamment des risques
peuvent être mises en avant nous avons
des compétiteurs dans notre espace
régional proche qui eux arrivent savent
exploiter
la proximité maritime alors que nous ça
va être une contrainte il en a ainsi
aussi de l'aménagement
du littoral
et on sent bien que il y a là un
problème qui va se poser dans notre
capacité
à pouvoir exploiter nos richesses c'est
un peu valable pour l'or en Guyane nous
on n'a pas d'or on n'a pas de métaux
précieux on n'a pas de richesse
naturelle très sec dans notre sol donc
on voit nous en tant que chambre de
commerce des difficultés se profilaient
quand on contracte des normes appliquées
à des petits territoires
merci
merci monsieur le Président mettons le
président joke de la CCI de Martinique
vous avez la parole président
sur
les pouvoirs locaux l'expression des
pouvoirs locaux du préfet je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'administration elle est
plutôt bien coordonnée en tout cas à la
Martinique on rencontre les bonnes
difficultés qui évoquées par le
président de la collé sur le point
important de la DA et les fonctionnaires
qui sont
pour certains d'entre eux j'ose le dire
très proche de l'écologie politique et
donc il y a peut-être en matière de
de pouvoir local plus adaptation en plus
de possibilité de déo préfet sur les sur
la coordination et certaines actions
notamment en matière en matière
environnementale et en matière de
développement économique on a
aujourd'hui certains arbitrages à faire
entre le développement économique et
protection accessible de l'environnement
ou principe de sécurité poussé à
l'extrême je crois que il y a peut-être
là à prendre en compte des
considérations locales de façon plus
intense mais en dehors de ça je trouve
que
nos préfets successifs ont eu en dehors
de la période covid effectivement les
décisions étaient clairement prises
ailleurs que sur notre territoire en
règle générale le préfet quand il est
convaincu arrive à convaincre la
démonstration centrale voilà voilà
bonjour mes chers collègues le président
madame messieurs comment avez-vous perçu
l'appel Fort de France en mai dernier
donc nous allons poursuivre dans le même
rythme avec la Guyane en premier ça va
Martin
la Guadeloupe et la Martinique si vous
le voulez bien
oui pour la Guyane
l'appel de Fort-de-France a été
satisfaction ou ce que cet appel a été
collectif unanime et simultanée et donc
ça a été une une satisfaction de voir
que tous les territoires ont pu
s'exprimer d'une seule voix et
assez collectivement pour autant
cet appel pour nous ne fait que
réaffirmer des diagnostics et des
constats qui sont très très largement
partagés et la partager de longue date
reste quand même à
trouver la méthode et à décliner et
peut-être à permettre la différenciation
quelqu'un selon les selon les
territoires
la préoccupation aussi derrière l'appel
de France c'est que s'il y a un
consensus extrêmement fort et
extrêmement large sur la nécessité de
faire évoluer
le cadre et de faire bouger les lignes
ça veut pas dire pour autant que il y a
une adhésion très forte à des
modifications qui seraient
l'introduction d'un changement
statutaire que certains appellent de
leurs vœux mais on est assez convaincus
que ce mouvement vers très marquée n'est
pas aujourd'hui un courant majoritaire
ni parmi les entreprises ni parmi la
population
voilà on est pour cette question de
Fort-de-France
monsieur bataille
oui pas grand chose à rajouter si ce
n'est que c'était cet appel voilà et
dans
des moyens de manifester un certain
nombre de malaises alors globalement
sociale ou sociétale bon la question
économique est cité en
dernière intention dans la rédaction de
cet appel mais c'est peut-être pas c'est
peut-être pas volontaire
ça ça revient à dire que
effectivement le déploiement des
politiques publiques plutôt que de les
de les de les dicter depuis un état
central vers des collectivités la
Constitution le permet de d'expérimenter
de différencier et c'est des logiques
des logiques qui seront plutôt de
consultation terrain pour construire la
politique la politique publique pourra
s'appliquer sur le territoire qui est
recherché dans le cadre de ces de cet
appel et avec des ambitions bien sûr de
réduction des inégalités derrière quand
je
la chose il y avait un exemple qu'on
avait auquel moi j'avais nous avions
pensé ici c'est vrai que quand les
politiques publiques sont déployées à
coup d'appel à projets de la Guyane
à parler tout à l'heure finalement ça
rate ça manque plutôt pardon ça la cible
quand il est déployé sur les territoires
et on l'a vu par exemple avec des choses
qui concernaient l'ADEME par exemple
donc
positif pour ce qui nous concerne en
tout cas dans la démarche
vous savez que nous avions eu à son
époque l'appel de Basse-Terre
donc les capitales pour habitude de
faire des appels donc l'appel de
Basse-Terre la plaque de Ford de France
en cela ça parle d'une bonne intention
c'est à dire de d'imaginer que tout le
mal développement des Outre-mer sont dus
finalement assez réducteur d'ailleurs
pour cela un problème lié à notre statut
prendre des exemples juste pour vous
dire ce qui nous préoccupe de façon
précise en ce moment c'est le fait de
pas avoir d'eau c'est pas si c'est
statutaire
le fait de au final d'avoir des
Sargasses
ils nous portent des normes problèmes
dans lequel on aurait pu imaginer que
l'État soit plus présent dans les
Sargasses n'est pas un problème lié
aux collectivités mais une dérive marine
d'algues qui viennent polluer la vie et
économiquement extrêmement difficile
et donc peut-être que ce que j'entends
je me permettrai pas ici de vous donner
mon impression personnelle mais ce que
j'entends des chefs d'entreprises
c'est que il y en a qui sont très
favorables d'autres très dubitatifs
et certains qui remettent les choses
avec des plus concrets est-ce que par
exemple le changement de statut nous
permettra d'être payé en temps et en
heure les entreprises qui ont plus de en
Guadeloupe 150 millions d'euros de
dettes auprès des collectivités c'est
des questions extrêmement concrètes
elle est finalement
les obstacles qui sont statutaires et
qui seront levés dès lors que on aurait
une évolution de statut
est-ce que cette évolution de statut
s'accompagnera de même de la même
solidarité nationale en ce qui concerne
les politiques publiques
autant de questions qui ça me rappelle
l'appel de Basse-Terre
où tout le monde se dit et pourquoi pas
et puis si vous demandez aux populations
il resteront avec un vote attentif en se
disant est-ce que c'est vraiment le
moment
donc je crois que finalement ça rejoint
un peu les compétences d'adaptation des
normes la capacité de gérer au plus près
du territoire tout le monde se dit bien
que le statut Pau tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui risque de poser quelques
soucis et en même temps tout le monde se
dit que l'évolution statutaire n'est pas
forcément la bonne réponse
et c'est là que peut-être que le 12 juin
la méthode de la façon dont nous voulons
prendre le problème
et à mon avis non pas lié à un simple
appel en disant finalement l'évolution
de statut va arriver tous les problèmes
mais de voir de façon méthodique
quels sont pour les différents
territoires qui ont déjà fait quelques
avancées différenciées avec des
résultats qu'on peut mesurer qu'elles
sont finalement les réelles obstacles à
notre développement économique et dans
quel cadre juridique devant les faire
évoluer je vous remercie
Monsieur Jacques
sur le point de l'évolution et l'appel
de Fort-de-France nous nous posons la
question à la Chambre de commerce de la
Martinique sur le timing la collectivité
territoire de Martinique c'est une jeune
collectivité sont format existe depuis à
peine 6 années et
on sait combien
la mise en route d'une institution de
cette nature peut être peut être longue
et compliquée sur la méthode non
s'interroge aussi parce que la
collectivité avec la compétences qui ont
été transférées au travers des
habilitations et je pense que notamment
la méditation énergie la méditation
transport on en a pas fait le bilan et
avant d'en faire le bilan on demande des
évolutions nous sommes plutôt
circonspect en disant
faisons le bilan de ce qui a été déjà
transféré comme compétences
supplémentaires au travers des
habilitations et revenons et revenons
vers la population parce que aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de base nous permettant de
dire qu'il est nécessaire de poursuivre
dans sa direction sans avoir en retour
d'expérience objectif et puis
Patrick de nombreux domaines qui sont
déjà de votre compétence on n'a pas
démontré notre efficacité
nous avons des problèmes d'eau qui sont
moins moins prégnants qu'en Guadeloupe
mais nous avons aussi des problèmes de
la Martinique la gestion des déchets
des transports ce sont des compétences
que dont nous disposons de façon pleine
et entière et pour lesquelles
aujourd'hui on n'a pas
on n'a pas démontré d'autres efficacité
donc je me dis qu'il faut peut-être
faire le bilan
examiner le véritable frein et ils ne
sont pas de notre point de vue
uniquement institutionnel puis j'ai
envie de dire que la loi 3DS permet
aujourd'hui de mettre en oeuvre de
compétences exploitons-la jusqu'au bout
et puis on verra si s'il faut aller s'il
faut aller plus loin je rappellerai que
en 2002 et 2010 les populations ont été
consultées à la Martinique et que les
réponses ont été plutôt claires et le
fait de remettre sans cesse sur le tapis
ces questions institutionnelles
ne sont pas de nature à
créer l'environnement
serein nécessaire au développement
économique
je vous remercie justement à la suite de
cet appel fort le France le président de
la République a lancé une feuille de
route renouveau pour les outre-mer qui
doit conduire dans six mois à un comité
interministériel aux outre-mer quand on
dit vous de cette feuille de route que
pensez-vous de la méthode et comment
voyez-vous la concrétisation des
objectifs annoncés par le ministre des
Outre-mer sur la création de valeur et
le développement des entreprises
pour pour la Guyane on est on est à la
fois
satisfait de la proposition et et
de l'ambition par contre c'est pas la
première c'est pas la première fois
qu'on participe à cet exercice et assez
régulièrement des attentes ne sont pas
ne sont pas satisfaites je crois qu'il y
a une très forte attente de lisibilité
et de et de définition d'un modèle de
développement pour la Guyane aujourd'hui
on a le sentiment Guyane qu'on est un
petit peu coincé avec toute une série de
l'interdiction et de protection et
notamment liée à des contraintes
environnementales on est conscient que
le territoire de la Guyane occupe une
place particulière dans dans l'équilibre
y compris mondial de
du fonctionnement de la planète pour
autant
ça nous ça doit pas être qu'une qu'une
série de qu'une série de contraintes et
aujourd'hui notre sentiment c'est que on
n'arrive pas à savoir quel est le quel
est fait en n'arrive pas à trouver quel
sera le cadre pour déterminer et valider
les actions à mettre en œuvre au service
d'un modèle de développement c'est à
dire que si on refuse de passer par une
étape d'industrialisation qui a un autre
sens et quand même nécessaire sur un sur
un laps de temps relativement court
alors il nous faut décliner comment on
réinscrire la Guyane dans une dans une
dynamique d'innovation et des
applications de ces innovations au
service de l'économie or là on se rend
compte que on avance très très lentement
sur les retombées de la biodiversité
guyanaise et la mise en application
locale donc on est à la fois
sous un régime d'interdiction et en même
temps sous un sous un faux rythme ou une
absence de rythme dans le déblocage
de politique de l'innovation en clair
cette feuille de cette feuille de route
pour nous c'est un à la fois un espoir
et ce sera une déception si on n'arrive
pas à travers la feuille de route à
avoir des actions concrètes au service
d'un projet de développement qui décrit
finalement le chemin
oui alors même constat il a pas de la
société Saint-Martin je vais pas je vais
pas répéter dans la dans la feuille de
route
la concertation évidemment est
importante mais il est bien noté que
l'État
s'appuiera très fortement sur sur les
collectivités et donc sur les acteurs du
terrain ce qui est plutôt une bonne idée
pour autant on revient aux questions de
moyens moyens en termes de
financement en moyenne en matière de
d'ingénierie pardon le voilà la question
continuera à se poser ici effectivement
le modèle
de développement global en tout cas les
grandes qui ne peuvent pas être
ne peuvent décrites on aura beaucoup de
mal à entretenir ce
comité interministériel ou en tout cas
le nourrir ou à l'alimenter il y a une
chose qui tient spécifiquement à la CCI
Saint-Martin c'est que nous on s'engage
sur des voies diversification de
l'activité économique parce qu'on l'a vu
moi je partage l'idée d'une d'une
activité touristique motrice de tout le
développement pour autant on l'a vu
après le cyclone et on l'a vu après
pendant et après le covid la nécessité
de pouvoir lisser ses chocs sur d'autres
secteurs de l'activité économique et
très important pour nous et là ça va
être un travail on va dire de terrain
avec
sous la l'arbitrage ou la bienveillance
de l'État à condition encore une fois
trouver des
y compris dans le cadre de France 2030
la feuille de route indique que les
financements seront encore à rechercher
pour les collectivités et les opérateurs
économiques
merci
je vais je vais essayer de répondre à
votre question elle est pas facile
depuis une décennie nous entendons de la
part du gouvernement quel qu'il soit
successifs quel que soit sa sensibilité
des mots qui nous interpellent le mot
autonomie et quelque chose qui est qui
devient de la part de nos ministres en
charge si je parle du ministre de
l'Outre-mer ou même d'autres
il n'est plus un tabou c'est-à-dire que
on avait eu l'habitude par un président
précédent d'avoir le statut à la carte
faisant espérer ainsi que la France
surtout celle qui est très éloignée
nous on est éloigné plus on a droit à un
statut plus ou moins encarté j'ai envie
de dire
comme si l'unité de la France pourrait
se faire à travers des statuts
différenciés de toutes les régions
françaises
et là c'est là qu'on touche à un moment
donné peut-être le fait de la de
l'adaptation au plus proche du terrain
j'ai comme j'ai quand même ce sentiment
que c'est pas le statut qui est en cause
mais les modes de gestion à l'intérieur
du territoire et que de vouloir répondre
en permanence avec des évolutions
statutaires me semble être pas tout à
fait conforme avec l'unité de la France
le gouvernement va loin puisque monsieur
dame à lui-même dit on pourrait profiter
de la fenêtre de tir de la réforme
constitutionnelle en Nouvelle-Calédonie
pour pouvoir trouver des nouveaux
statuts dans l'outre-mer
on voit bien là que le gouvernement
ouvre une porte qui peut nourrir
quelques espoirs moi je voudrais
simplement vous dire la chose suivante
il y a un mal développement notre mère
nous avons des populations qui sont plus
pauvres que dans l'Hexagone puisque
le revenu moyen y est inférieur les
salaires moyens ils sont inférieurs
tout ça nourrit des espoirs de meilleur
développement
et bien sûr quand ces populations on
leur dit que c'est le cadre
institutionnel créé ce mal développement
ils ont envie d'y croire
un peu différent parce que nous sommes
un peu plus pragmatique
et l'observation que nous faisons
aujourd'hui et c'est un problème de
méthode puisque je veux revenir à la
question que vous m'avez posé la méthode
et qu'on a la chance ici d'avoir des
collectivités qui ont fait un choix
différencié par temps cela de la Réunion
en passant par la Guadeloupe la
Martinique la Saint Martin et
Saint-Barthélémy avec des capacités
différentes je rappelle que
Saint-Barthélemy à Tahiti le plus loin
possible tout en restant par rapport à
Saint-Martin qui n'a pas ses capacités
d'adaptation
puisqu'elle elle prélève un droit de
quai donc un droit de douane renonçant
finalement à certaines aides qui sont
européennes nous on a envie dans la
méthode de faire un inventaire
finalement de toutes ces
différenciations
de les mesurer économiquement dans la
capacité qu'on donnait à ces différents
territoires
l'efficacité économique puisque nous
sommes nous purement dans l'économie
de voir si
finalement ce droit commun
que certains ont par rapport à d'autres
il n'y a pas conduit à des
différenciations de solidarité nationale
c'est-à-dire que finalement on a plus de
pouvoir mais moins de moyens alors moi
si vous me donnez plus de pouvoir et
moins de moyens je serai peut-être faire
un peu mieux mais de là à tout compenser
ça risque d'être difficile et donc moi
je crois qu'il faut véritablement dans
cette méthode on y aille pas à pas qu'on
regarde bien qu'on puisse cibler et je
vois souvent qu'on revient les mêmes
problèmes les mêmes problèmes que ce
soit Saint-Barth Saint-Martin etc c'est
notre capacité avec la DL de pouvoir
adapter notre développement économique
qui tourne autour de certains nombre de
contraintes extrêmement difficiles à
appliquer dans nos territoires
on aurait terminé
Monsieur Jacques
oui je suis sur la méthode je pense que
faire un état des lieux comme le propose
aujourd'hui le gouvernement et puis
après faire des propositions concrètes
ça me paraît la bonne méthode pour
avancer mais on a connu les assises des
Outre-mer avant ça on a eu c'est ça pour
un autre nom on a l'habitude des grandes
rencontres et des grandes messes au
cours desquelles nous sommes consultés
et puis au final
ils n'en sont pas grand chose donc
on reste dubitatif on se dit qu'il faut
effectivement faire l'état des lieux il
faut faire des propositions concrètes et
voir dans quelle mesure ces propositions
concrètes sont reprises mais ce qui est
important de notre point de vue à son
e-commerceuse c'est que le projet de
développement soit co-construit et une
des propositions du ministre qui
consiste à dire que les plans de
convergence même s'ils doivent changer
de nom seront à la fois consignés par
l'État et collectivité mais aussi les
acteurs économiques ça nous paraît aller
dans le bon sens il faut
qu'effectivement les réflexions en
matière de développement
prenne en compte la vie des acteurs
économiques on le voit bien nous sommes
seront consultés sur ce projet de
renouveau on sera certainement associé
nous sommes déjà associés à quelques
réflexions mais ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'au final les décisions soient
co-construites et que
notre avis sur les domaines que nous
maîtrisons les mieux soit prise en
compte j'en ai terminé
je vous remercie ces débats
institutionnels
à propos d'une éventuelle révision
constitutionnelle sur vos territoires
a-t-il créé selon vous une une angoisse
une instabilité défavorable aux
anticipations économiques ou au
contraire cela ouvre-t-il des
perspectives de développement
alors pour pour la Guyane rappelée que
on a eu en 2017 des mouvements sociaux
très importants avec des blocages très
longs la totalité du de la Région Guyane
et qu'à l'issue de ces blocages on a
développé à la fois des accords de
Guyane et et un dispositif de suivi de
ces accords de Guy
c'est tout ça pour dire que on est
depuis 2017 dans une une
dynamique de d'examen et de et de
changement et de volonté de faire bouger
la ligne pour autant concrètement sur le
terrain
tout enfin les résultats des accords de
Guyane sont relativement
contrastées
mais à côté de ça ça a permis aussi de
mobiliser et d'avoir une partie très
active de certains de certains
héritiers de ces accords de Guyane donc
je pense à des collectifs qui ont
persisté après 2017 qui aujourd'hui sont
à la manœuvre sur la question du
changement satuaire tout ça pour dire
qu'on a un monde économique qui a subi
beaucoup plus les accords de Guyane qui
n'en a pour l'instant
tirer les avantages et que par contre on
a développé un groupe un petit peu actif
sur le changement statutaire alors la
question de changement statutaire
aujourd'hui elle a été actée par le
congrès des élus donc on y travaille les
travaux en cours à la auquel participent
la CCI ne se consacrent exclusivement à
la dimension institutionnelle veut dire
que on ne se pose pas les questions des
objectifs poursuivi des contenus des
politiques publiques qu'il faudra mettre
en oeuvre demain alors sur ce débat
constitutionnel on a des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui disent bon ce truc là c'est
illisible on sait pas trop ce différents
sortir et puis de toute façon parti
comme c'est parti ça ne sortira jamais
et donc on a cette espèce de de risques
selon nous d'un décalage entre
finalement des travaux qui avance à bas
bruit et qui ne porte que sur des
aspects je dirais quasi mécanique d'un
fonctionnement d'un territoire et des
acteurs économiques qui sont pris par
leurs difficultés du quotidien et qui
regardent avec beaucoup de distance
finalement ce qui est en train de se
jouer alors
le vrai risque selon nous c'est que à un
moment donné quand il s'agira de se
prononcer sur la loi organique et bien
on arrive à déblocage relativement fort
en ce qui concerne Saint-Martin comme je
disais tout à l'heure
économique de manière générale dans
l'État était associé aux travaux
d'évolution institutionnelle dans tous
les cas pas pas directement et pas pour
construire ce qui pourrait être le
modèle économique de cette nouvelle
collectivité
les chefs d'entreprise bon bien sûr eux
sont pris dans leurs actualités
respectives et dans les difficultés
commerciales concurrentielles des
questions de prix des questions de
d'achat des questions trésorerie qui
sont finalement très indépendantes de de
cette évolution il y a quand même
quelques quelques aspects sur lesquels
on n'a pas totalement transformé l'essai
j'ai deux exemples qui me viennent en
tête premier exemple c'est cette carte
judiciaire qui fait que la
on va dire la juridiction commerciale
qui aurait pu suivre cette évolution
statutaire pour la collectivité n'a pas
n'a pas évolué et le
Registre du Commerce et des Sociétés
restent celui enfin reste hébergé par le
tribunal mixte de commerce de
Basse-Terre et deuxième exemple la
qui est aussi qui est aussi encore
sur le sur le territoire de la
Guadeloupe donc c'est pas une
incertitude si vous voulez mais c'est
une forme de d'absence de lisibilité
complète de ce que pourrait être le la
transition voilà totale et définitive en
matière en matière institutionnelle
alors bien sûr toutes les questions de
justice sont évidemment galiennes pour
autant on construit ici physiquement des
organisations
une chambre détachée qui se
transformerait on a un tribunal de
proximité ou l'ensemble des affaires
pourraient être pourraient être jugé ou
en tout cas
truite mais c'est si vous voulez c'est
ça nous qui manque peut-être dans le
dans
ce débat en tout cas si on devait nous
encore aller un petit peu plus loin et
comme je les ai tout à l'heure il n'est
pas question et ça ça a été vu avec avec
la collectivité territoriale de renoncer
à certaines compétences ou d'en demander
de nouvelles comme les collègues qui
sont autour de la table aujourd'hui
passent pas après avoir fait une juste
évaluation et un juste inventaire et
nous on a voilà encore une fois quinze
ans de recul sur ses affaires
oui merci alors l'incertitude des
populations
pas vraiment leur préoccupations sont
ailleurs
mais je pense que le moment si ça devait
se faire je ne sais pas quels sont avec
les modalités si elles se rend
consultées ou pas
elle donneront leur avis concernant les
affaires beaucoup plus préoccupés par
les troubles publics
le niveau
comment dire de la délinquance
des crimes
le trafic de drogue que de l'évolution
institutionnelle qui est quelque chose
qui
quelque part et rythmé comme l'a dit le
président Philippe joke par des
questions qu'on nous pose à peu près
tous les 10 ans donc bon je pense que le
monde des affaires a pris note de cette
volonté des élus d'avoir plus de pouvoir
pour essayer de résoudre les problèmes
donc plus proche du terrain
donc je crois pas que ça soit
véritablement
une vraie question mais j'entends de
plus en plus de ça c'est juste
que je vois autour de moi j'entends le
plus de personnes du monde des affaires
qui me demande qui disent bon ça va être
un peu inéluctable
et qui se demande dans quel contexte
cela va être fait
est-ce que il y aura une réécriture des
articles
73-74 comment les populations vont-elles
être concernées
comment tout ça va évoluer
donc c'est pas à mon sens c'est pas
quelque chose qui va faire fuir les
investisseurs ou qui va priver de
lisibilité les investisseurs actuels
dans le cadre de leur de leurs
investissements qui sont plus préoccupés
par la lourdeur administrative liée à
notre capacité d'investissement qui est
de plus en plus long
et au phénomène sociaux dont ils sont
très inquiets et à une conjoncture
internationale
dont chacun d'entre nous est bien
au-delà de la France est totalement
préoccupé et pour lesquels on est nourri
tous les jours
d'information assourdissant
la préoccupation des chefs d'entreprise
et celle que vient d'évoquer Patrick
galgulée
pas beaucoup de visibilité donc il y a
déjà des incertitudes et on a le
sentiment qu'on veut rajouter une
incertitude à aux incertitudes que nous
connaissons mais comment Guadeloupe les
choses reprises considèrent que cette
évolution est inéluctable il y a une
volonté des élus volonté politique très
forte d'aller vers plus d'autonomie et
on se prépare tranquillement à ses
évolutions après est-ce que
d'autres acteurs économiques
venus de l'extérieur invincibrancher de
nous c'est une question qui peut se
poser
les acteurs locaux sont déjà là et
continueront à investir et continueront
à jouer le rôle mais ce que
proposer de façon permanente ces
questions en les liant à
un mal développement est-ce que ça va
venir des investisseurs hexagonaux ou de
la Caraïbe je n'en suis pas certain
voilà c'est
le retour que j'ai que j'ai des acteurs
économiques de la de la Martinique
en Martinique en Guadeloupe le congrès
des élus engagé des travaux depuis
plusieurs mois
êtes-vous associé et dans la négative
comment pourriez-vous être davantage
associé en tant qu'acteur économique
monsieur
bon c'est une c'est une forme de
réflexion qui a été initié
peut-être une dizaine d'années déjà
puisque le Congrès se réunit
en Guadeloupe à l'initiative d'un des
deux présidents de région ou du
département
pour parler de certains noms de
préoccupations dans les évolutions
institutionnelles
on y est alors il y a un problème de
méthode dans le cadre de l'association
des forces économiques
mais il y a un problème de méthode tout
court c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui je
suis pas convaincu même si le but c'est
au final
de trouver un cadre institutionnel qui
soit plus adapté
à la
au développement économique et social de
nos populations donc partant de bons
sentiments
je ne suis pas convaincu
on est mis bientôt à plat qu'on est
observé ce qui se passe autour de nous
pour voir s'il véritablement c'est plus
efficace et moi je reviens toujours et
je le dis aux autres
nos amis
président de chambre on doit faire des
retours d'expérience on a la chance
aujourd'hui d'avoir une collectivité
unique à la Martinique qui est
différente de nous puisque nous nous
avons toujours Région Département
pendant longtemps j'ai entendu dire que
le gros problème c'était qu'on avait
deux collectivités avec un
enchèresonnement de compétences donc
avec beaucoup d'espoir je regarde de
l'efficacité martiniquaise dans le
Président
nous parler mais je regarde je fais pas
de procès d'attention
j'observe j'observe avec Saint-Martin
comment tout ça fonctionne
Saint-Barthélémy et d'autres c'est
plutôt pour le bassin Atlantique puisque
c'est
sur l'autre bassin Pacifique parce qu'on
est moins on est moins directement
concerné
mais moi mon sentiment c'est que j'ai
pas eu l'impression que pourraient soit
significatif suffisamment lissible
et qui mériterait qu'on si on gage de
façon
comment dire pour trouver finalement des
réponses à nos problématiques c'est
peut-être là que c'est peut-être là que
ça devient compliqué quoi
au final avant on avait aucune
expérience maintenant on a quelques
lisibilité on a des retours d'expérience
et on peut se dire à travers tout ça
comment ça fonctionne et donc oui on est
associé oui on est invité oui nous avons
des contacts
assez proches avec
les différents présidents des
collectivités
la question aujourd'hui qui se pose à
nous c'est quel est le meilleur statut
quels sont les meilleurs domaines de
compétence où doit-on exercer la
compétence la plus proche qu'est-ce
qu'on doit simplifier pour que au final
l'entreprise
puisse permettre de créer plus de
richesses plus d'espoir plus de
d'emplois pour nos populations je
rappelle que le taux de chômage même si
je pense qu'il y a quelque chose qui
m'interpelle parce que on a plus de 25%
de chômage 28 et pour autant les
entreprises ont extrêmement de mal à
trouver du personnel pour travailler
donc ça pose quand même ça pose quand
même un souci majeur dans les outre
un peu le seul à parler des deux
collectivités qui se réunissent autour
puisque nous sommes nous avons ce
contexte singulier par rapport à tous
mes collègues qui sont ici d'avoir
encore une région et départements comme
ça l'est à la Réunion
nous on a Martinique le Congrès n'a pas
associé les acteurs économiques aux
travaux il y a une commission à Doc de
ce congrès qui est chargé de faire le
bilan
et qui est auditionnait les acteurs
économiques mais s'agissant du congrès
lui-même de son nous y sommes pas
associés donc je peux difficilement je
le regrette parce que
le Congrès pour être l'occasion de
co-construire ce projet de développement
que nous attendons depuis de nombreuses
années et pas seulement s'arrêter aux
évolutions institutionnelles mais nous
n'y sommes pas ceci
je vous remercie je le congrès des élus
s'est réuni aussi en Guyenne au mois de
mars est-ce que monsieur cambril nous
pourrait nous faire un retour de
l'expérience les acteurs économiques
ont-ils été associés à ce congrès
oui là alors les acteurs économiques la
Chambre de commerce participe en tant
que en tant que
partie prenante donc au travaux au
Congrès c'est surtout les élus qui
s'expriment le le sujet pour la pour la
Guyane c'est vraiment cette focalisation
aujourd'hui sur des questions
strictement institutionnelles
le
les travaux préparatoires ont un moment
donné fait un raccourci extrêmement fort
et et plutôt tactique qui consiste à
dire écouter changeons de statut et vous
verrez que le projet viendra tout
naturellement une fois qu'on aura levé
les verrous statutaires et ça a été
présenté de telle façon que finalement
il n'y a pas franchement eu de débat sur
ces questions là donc aujourd'hui on a
un congrès qui au final est parti sur
cette sur cette base là et donc
la question des contenus n'est pas
encore n'est pas encore à l'ordre du
jour et on travaille un peu curieusement
à valider des choses ou à réfléchir à ce
que ce que serait la proposition
d'organisation institutionnelle de la
Guyane sont pour autant
mener
clairement enfin trancher clairement un
certain nombre de questions qui vont
être fondamentales et et
travailler ensuite à comment elle
pourrait se décliner alors parmi les
questions qui sont fondamentales c'est
quelle position on aura vis-à-vis de
l'immigration et et de ce qu'elle
alimente le l'économie informelle quelle
position quel équilibre on trouvera
entre l'exploitation de nos ressources
industrialisation et la protection du
territoire
quelle quelle règle du jeu sur la
répartition des terres puisque plus de
95% du territoire appartient à l'État et
que l'État s'est engagé les restitué
mais on sait pas plus comment comment
les choses vont faire c'est question là
n'étant pas posées parce que si elles
étaient posées à priori ça aurait
tendance à faire exploser les les
consensus à minima sur le changement
institutionnel donc on les évite et ce
qui fait que au final
on est sur quelque chose qui ne traite
que d'un aspect je dirais quasi droit
constitue
du sujet
pensez-vous alors qu'il faille inscrire
dans la Constitution un principe de
co-construction des politiques publiques
outre-mer dans des domaines de murant de
la compétence de l'État voir celle qui
serait transférée au collectivités
comment ce principe selon vous pourrez
traduire dans le respect des compétences
de chacun
alors
il nous semble que cette question de la
proposition de la co-construction ce
principe est un principe
tout à fait tout à fait nécessaire et
pertinent pour autant les ambitions ne
porteront leurs fruits que si on arrive
à à faire référence aux projets de
développement et au contractualisation
qui ont été prises en déclinaison de ce
projet c'est-à-dire que le principe tel
quel mais si on la dose pas à un
document d'orientation
inscrit dans la durée largement partagée
qui sert de règles du jeu à chacun ça ça
va manquer d'efficacité l'autre sujet
sur le sur les questions de de
co-construction c'est qui est autorisé à
apporter sa pierre et là encore une fois
il faut que les acteurs économiques la
voix du monde économique soit
représentée et soit
prise en considération c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui si on l'époque que des
problèmes sociaux dans une Guyane où il
y a 40% de l'économie informelle c'est
clair que à un moment donné la voix du
monde économique doit être entendue
autant et voir peut-être
à part égale avec cette des
collectivités aujourd'hui on a des élus
qui arrivent à défendre des positions
qui consiste à dire écouter
l'informer c'est un mal nécessaire parce
que il y a tellement de pauvreté et il y
a tellement la situation est tellement
grave que je ne peux pas m'attaquer à
l'informel sous peine de déstabiliser
complètement ma société ma population
d'un point de vue économique c'est pas
en temps là c'est à dire que la
trajectoire qu'elle a l'autre on voit
que l'informel prend des proportions de
plus en plus grandes et que le phénomène
s'accélère à terme ça convaincre la
totalité de l'activité économique de la
Guyane et c'est la mort des entreprises
guyanaise donc un moment donné il faut
que dans ces questions pour construction
on fasse référence à des sujets de fonds
qui doivent être posés en amont
et qu'on fasse référence à des
contractualisations qui sont qui sont
posées et encore une fois
le point de vue du monde économique doit
être
largement considéré
pour ce qui concerne la CCI de
Saint-Martin
la Constitution offre déjà un certain
nombre d'outils législatif qui
permettent
on l'a dit tout à l'heure la loi 3DS qui
permet
d'expérimenter différencier etc la
co-construction encore une fois elle est
inscrite dans dans la Constitution
française et le sentiment qui qui peut
qui peut être
primé ici au stade de cette discussion
c'est de se demander si la
décentralisation telle qu'elle est menée
aujourd'hui en France n'est pas un peu
je vais employé un terme peut-être un
peu fort mais n'est pas un peu complexée
si on regarde par exemple d'autres pays
d'Europe pour lesquels
on la décentralisation est allé beaucoup
plus loin où les régions ont des
collectivités territoriales mais bon des
régions au sens européen du terme ont
des pouvoirs normatifs
relativement importants et ce qui permet
de répondre à des enjeux de territoire
directement
torgibles et directement directement
contrôlable par des équipes par des
équipes exécutifs pardon qui
bien sûr rendent compte mais qui peuvent
qui peuvent adapter au plus aux réalités
de leur territoire donc c'est ça la
République française et décentralisée
mais
au sens peut-être des Outre-mer mais
c'est peut-être le cas aussi dans
d'autres régions de France avec un pas
encore supplémentaire peut-être
décomplexé cette ce processus d'exercice
des compétences au niveau au niveau
territorial et le plus territorial
possible
la co-construction bon en réalité sur le
plan purement institutionnel cadre
juridique bon on a des avis à donner on
est consulté mais bon chacun dans son
domaine de compétence exerce son pouvoir
et donc
on n'est pas complètement
associée j'ai envie de dire dans la
décision c'est tout à fait le
fonctionnement normal
des
institutions en revanche en revanche ce
qu'on ce qu'on voit quand même et ça
c'est peut-être en fonction des
relations des uns et des autres avec vos
différentes
institutions c'est que quand ça touche
au secteur économique la Chambre de
commerce de Guadeloupe est largement
consultés
et
on peut
on peut on donne on participe à cette
cette construction mais il y a pas de
cadre c'est à dire qu'en réalité il y a
un cadre de consultation on va donner
notre avis et puis par la suite
il sera suivi ou pas j'ai envie
une chambre entre guillemets
une chambre qui va être consultée sur
les questions économiques parce qu'on a
une expertise et donc logiquement cette
expertise est mise et mise à profit en
revanche
on n'a pas véritablement comment dire
un cadre où on doit se réunir par
exemple je sais pas tous les trimestres
pour aborder des thèmes bien précis sur
l'économie
on n'a pas de réflexion stratégique sur
une vision économique qui soit
consignée dans un document
on va avoir on va faire fonctionner les
instances dans lesquelles on doit être
consulté
et donc
je pense que notre capacité
co-construire vient plus de notre
relation de proximité avec ceux qui ont
la charge que le cadre
voilà je pourrais dire c'est que
effectivement il faut il faut que les
politiques publiques outrevières soient
peu construites entre l'État et les
collectivités mais aussi les acteurs
économiques
je partage le point de vue de mes
collègues présidents de chambre de
commerce
je sais pas s'il faut la suivre la
prostitution ou si simplement au moment
des contrats de convergence quel que
soit le nom qu'il sera donné il est vrai
association des acteurs économiques à
ces contrats moi je prends l'exemple de
la Martinique j'ai moins de chance qu'en
Guadeloupe
la préparation du programme opérationnel
européen
économiques n'ont pas été associés et
quand on sait le proie et l'importance
des fonds fédères dans le développement
fédéraux les quatre chevaux qui sont
gérés par la collectivité quand on sait
l'importance de ces fonds de
développement économique que les élus ni
associent pas les acteurs économiques
mais c'est pas seulement maintenant
c'était déjà vrai lors de la nature
précédentes ça pose question donc est-ce
que c'est un problème constitutionnel
est-ce que ce problème de relation
est-ce que ce problème d'hommes est-ce
que est-ce qu'il faut l'inscrire la
Constitution j'en sais rien ce qu'il
faut elle discutablement c'est que le
projet de développement de nos
territoires soit co-construit et ça
emporte à la fois la position de l'État
la position des collectes de la
collectivité majeure des collectivités
locales et les acteurs économiques c'est
ensemble qu'on arrivera à régler ces
problèmes de mal développement que nous
connaissons depuis des années si on
travaille pas sur l'éducation sur la
formation
si on n'a pas cette gestion privée les
employés des compétences nous aurons
toujours ces niveaux chômage élevés avec
des emplois qui sont non pourvus on a on
a de vraies problématiques à résoudre
collectivement et je sais pas à quel
niveau il faut inscrire cette
reconstruction en tous les cas il faut
qu'elle soit effective donc je vous
remercie justement je vais rebondir mon
évoque souvent le manque d'ingénierie
dans les territoires vous avez tout à
l'heure évoqué les problèmes d'eau des
problèmes du quotidien
pour lesquels les habitants attendent
des solutions et des réponses et souvent
on parle de problèmes d'ingénierie
est-ce que dans les dans les structures
des de l'économie des sociétés que il y
a ce problème
vous le déplorez et que pensez-vous de
développer vous avez parlé de formation
mais justement de rapprocher des
formations
au plus près des territoires à savoir
des une école d'ingénieurs par bassin
pensez-vous que cela puisse être
réalisable
dans
chaque bassin
ultra
alors pour pour la Guyane effectivement
on est
à tout point de vue toucher par ce par
cette ce manque d'ingénierie je crois
qu'on travaille dans de direction c'est
essayer de essayer de garder un minimum
d'outils pour compenser le manque
attractivité du territoire et faire
encore
référence en sorte que les compétences
qui sont qui sont absents plus à arriver
de l'extérieur mais surtout c'est
s'inscrire sur un dispositif de
formation et de qualification alors en
cela les chambres de commerce et en tout
cas la Chambre de commerce de la Guyane
et tout à fait active donc on développe
des des filières on est suffisamment
souple pour construire les filières avec
les besoins des besoins des entreprises
et en ce qui concerne les qualifications
on est tout à fait tout à fait partant
et disposer à
et disposer à y travailler notamment sur
des niveaux des livres ingénieurs comme
l'autre aspect qui nous paraît
aujourd'hui important c'est c'est
finalement un petit peu un défaut de un
défaut de mutualisation ou un défaut de
capacité à mutualisation alors c'est
vrai en ce qui concerne les
collectivités entre elles et les
collectivités avec avec l'État on se dit
que il manque du personnel on a il
manque des compétences et des
qualifications un petit peu partout on a
un paysage atro et curieusement chacun
reste un petit peu
isolé alors que on fonctionne en mode
projet et avec une logique de
mutualisation on arriverait probablement
pour un certain temps en tout cas à
compenser un petit peu ce manque de
mutualisation on a aussi aujourd'hui une
ouverture qui qui peut-être donnera des
résultats et qui nous faut regarder avec
les
contra
de l'économie du spatial un certain
nombre d'entreprises très pointues avec
des compétences tout à fait tout à fait
en pointe
[Musique]
sont aujourd'hui en fin arrive
aujourd'hui à dégager des marges de
démarches de manœuvre pour se consacrer
à d'autres sujets que des sujets
spatiaux donc là l'enjeu est de savoir
finalement si
on arrivera à mobiliser ses compétences
au service du territoire ou si les
entreprises du spatial qui auraient un
chiffre d'affaires aujourd'hui trop
réduit finirait par quitter le parti tel
département donc
la formation c'est la solution d'avenir
entre temps il y a des solutions
temporaires qui nous faut mettre en
oeuvre et qui aujourd'hui sont peines à
se développer
pour Saint-Martin même sujet taux
chômage très important notamment chez
les jeunes
et des femmes et pour autant des
difficultés pour les entreprises à
recruter donc on a un stock environ de
5000 demandeurs d'emploi en permanence
sur le territoire
la CCI comme je les ai tout à l'heure
travail au sein de groupe de travail
avec
la collectivité la présentation
officielle les centres de formation les
CFA les plus en plus actifs aussi sur le
sur le loyer
au monde organise le plus régulièrement
possible des des rencontres très très
opérationnelles entre des demandeurs
d'emploi
pourra préparer et puis des offreurs des
entreprises qui qui sont prêtes à
recruter qui pour la plupart pour en
avoir discuté avec certains secteurs
notamment dans le bâtiment mais aussi
dans les métiers de la notice de manière
générale qui n'ont pas de problème de
trésorerie qui n'ont pas de problème
pour embaucher mais qui se trouve face à
un manque un manque de main d'oeuvre
très important et alors on a aussi nous
un problème de timing qu'on a relevé
dans le cadre des réunions du service de
l'emploi c'est que les grands chantiers
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure de
reconstruction qui continue avec la de
nouveaux collèges
plus un centre culturel plus
un plateau d'activités nautiques on n'a
pas on a des entreprises mais on n'a pas
de
de professionnelle spécialisés dans tel
ou tel type de métier du bâtiment qui
sont tout de suite formés et qui sont
tout de suite aptes à travailler ils
sont en train d'être formés mais on va
avoir un petit décalage
qui sera
plus compliqué à réduire mais qu'on
s'attache on s'attache à faire la CCI
elle est aussi sur des programmes
de formation supérieure alors ici on n'a
pas d'offre directement et on profite
évidemment de nos de nos îles voisines
pour voilà mutualiser des formations
universitaires ce qu'on a réussi à faire
cette année c'est de pouvoir proposer un
cycle certifiant avec HEC Paris qui a
qui a formé voilà
12 12 chefs d'entreprise à
à une haute on va dire
enfin je veux dire une formation à haute
qualité managériale on a appelé
ça qui permet voilà de professionnaliser
la fonction de chef d'entreprise et de
professionnaliser
à haut niveau l'ensemble des fonctions
d'une entreprise management RH gestion
commerciale gestion financière et aussi
embrasser l'ensemble des enjeux de
responsabilités sociales et
environnementale à des entreprises et on
va continuer dans ce dans ce rythme là
avec d'autres grandes écoles sous des
formats hybrides et là on arrive si vous
voulez à à la fois ce que je me disais
tout à l'heure des formations on va dire
de base mais des formations
pour pour remplir les les
besoins en main d'oeuvre opérationnelle
sur des travaux sur des grands marchés
de travaux mais aussi des professions
intellectuelles qu'on peut qu'on peut
aussi développer de cette manière là et
on essaye de réduire ce gap entre l'idée
tout à l'heure 5000 demandeurs d'emploi
quasiment permanents et puis des besoins
en main d'oeuvre très tendus de la part
des
merci pour juste utiliser mon temps pour
pas être redondant avec mes collègues
j'aimerais juste porter une réflexion
qui va dans le droit fil de la question
précédente et celle que vous venez de
poser
à mon sens
dès lors que l'État a décidé
que les grandes infrastructures
publiques qui étaient précédemment gérée
par les Chambres de Commerce
puisse être co-géré avec l'État et les
collectivités vous avez beaucoup
affaibli
la puissance des chambres de commerce à
se concerter avec nos pouvoirs
politiques en réalité
nous avions un équilibre qui est naturel
entre les représentants des
entrepreneurs du pays il y avait élu en
son sein un Bureau des membres qui
avaient été un bureau et un Président de
chambre et nous gérions
des grandes infrastructures publiques et
qui à mon sens nous avons démontré notre
capacité à bien les gérer
il y a jamais eu de problème ou les
avions pas se poser les marchandises
préparer etc et je crois que c'était je
me permets cette réflexion c'était un
moyen de nous associer naturellement
dans un cadre de réflexion des gestion
des grands équipements structurants avec
les pouvoirs politiques et ça là je
faisais naturellement puisque nous
étions nous-mêmes
propriétaires gestionnaire exploitants
de ces grands investissements publics
il aurait pu en être ainsi
éventuellement d'autres tels que
l'eau les marinas etc donc tout ce qui
touche directement finalement à un
intérêt général
et nous sommes nous en tant que chambre
de commerce garant de l'intérêt général
puisqu'on n'a pas de distribution de
dividendes donc on n'a pas d'intérêt ni
à court terme ni à moyen terme de faire
des résultats nous sommes là pour gérer
les investissements publics dans
l'intérêt du plus grand nombre des
entrepreneurs mais aussi de chacun de
nos habitants des îles respectives voilà
donc pour le reste je souscris à ce qui
a été dit par la Région Guyane je vais
totalement souscrire à ce que je ne sais
pas qui va être dit par mon collègue
Philippe job de la Martinique
sur la formation
c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui mais je
voudrais faire un petit rappel sur le
financement de l'apprentissage
on développe l'apprentissage simplement
le mode de financement a été a été revu
récemment
on passe par des OPCO qui qui en
découlent apprentis qui sont plus
faibles que ce que nous avons en tout le
fonctionnement mais surtout jusqu'à lors
nous arrivions à ouvrir des formations
de 15 16 des commandes de 15 16
étudiants apprentis sur deux années
parce que ça correspondait aux besoins
du territoire aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'équilibre économique on ne les ouvre
pas donc c'est jeudi pas et ils ne
reviennent pas et donc je crois qu'il y
a sur cette volonté de de d'assurer des
formations au plus près du territoire à
revoir le mode de financement de la
formation et notamment de la formation
d'apprentissage ce n'est pas l'objet de
l'entretien d'aujourd'hui mais je tenais
à le faire remarquer parce que nous
avons cette volonté dans les chambres de
de contribuer à l'élévation du niveau en
matière de formation en matière de
formation mais il faut nous donner les
moyens il faut donner au centre de
formation d'apprenti des moyens de
régler pas de problème je répète ce que
je dis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
sur la gestion prévisionnelle des
emplois des compétences si on veut
vraiment
avoir une vision à moyen terme de
développement il faut à l'échelle du
territoire prévoir cette gestion privée
compétences ça suppose qu'on est
ensemble défini le modèle économique à
partir de ce modèle on sait quelles sont
les secteurs sur lesquels nous aurons
besoin de compétences on lance les
formations et là on sera efficace
aujourd'hui on a trop de jeunes qui
choisissent des formations un peu hasard
sans savoir si elle correspondent aux
voisins du territoire et on s'étonne
après coup qu'il ne reste pas sur notre
territoire donc je crois qu'il y a
vraiment sur ces problèmes de
compétences et de formation un travail à
faire à faire ensemble je voudrais je
voudrais aussi assister sur le fait que
on peut pas décider seul de ce que
veulent nos jeunes il faut aussi les
associer à la réflexion et très souvent
les politiques dans leur coin décide de
ce qui est bon pour le territoire sans
penser à cette jeunesse et ce n'était
pas le cas en Guyane mais Martinique et
Guadeloupe nous connaissons un exode des
jeunes qui est massif un vieillissement
de la population et tout cela va poser à
terme des problèmes des problèmes de
financement
la dépendance pour les collectivités
mais aussi de niveau d'équilibre
économique aux entreprises parce que
quand vous passez d'un territoire de 400
000 habitants ce que contient la
Martinique il y a quelques années à des
projections à 280 000 vous comprenez
bien que que l'enjeu il est autre de mon
point de vue il est autre que
institutionnel mais s'agissant du niveau
de d'ingénierie nécessaire oui il y a il
y a besoin d'avoir dans nos bassins
respectifs des écoles d'ingénieurs il y
a un projet à Martinique qui commence
bientôt avec l'INSA linsa Lyon et on
considère cette formation qui a été
initié aussi par la Chambre de commerce
on considère qu'il y a à mutualiser avec
nos amis de la Guadeloupe de la Guyane
de Saint-Martin pour que cette cette
école d'ingénieur trouve sa place mais
s'agissant de l'ingénierie des
collectivités je voudrais simplement
faire remarquer qu'en terme de
fonctionnaires de catégorie A je
une dotation supérieure légèrement
supérieure à la moyenne nationale et ça
n'empêche ça nous empêche pas d'avoir
les mêmes problèmes de
de paiement de des fournisseurs
des entreprises dans les délais par les
collectivités avec des éléments qui sont
anormalement longs ça nous empêche pas
d'avoir des problèmes de l'accès à l'eau
et des problèmes de traitement des
déchets donc c'est dire que ce n'est pas
seulement un problème de compétence
humaine ou de gestion des ressources
humaines c'est aussi et surtout un
problème de volonté politique
je vous remercie nous allons
nous arrivons en termes de notre
audition mais avant de nous laisser je
vais laisser la parole à notre collègue
Victor jasmin qui souhaite poser une
question et après au président pour
conclure mais je vous remercie
infiniment pour ces
éclairages et je souscris parfaitement à
ce que vous venez de dire sur la
formation professionnelle et sur la
montée en compétences et en valeur et
l'importance de garder sinon de mettre
en place les conditions pour faire
revenir
nos cerveaux qui sont partis dans les
territoires au service de leur
territoire je vous remercie
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention vos différentes
interventions et j'adhère vraiment la
plupart des choses que vous avez dit
dans la mesure où sur nos territoires il
y a de vrais problématiques à régler et
qui pourraient contribuer énormément à
l'amélioration des conditions de
développement économique et c'est
important que les délais de paiement par
exemple soient réduite qu'il y ait l'eau
on fait qu'on est vraiment à appréhender
différemment un certain nombre de ces
problématiques alors concernant
l'organisation des branches
professionnelles également c'est un
sujet je crois aussi que la plupart des
des collectivités par des collectivités
mais des établissements publics de
d'éducation
on leur sait au sein de leur conseil
d'administration des représentants de
vos différentes chambres je crois ou en
tout cas il y a des personnes qualifiées
qui sont la plupart du temps des chefs
entreprise alors je voudrais savoir
est-ce que ces personnes font des
retours
vers vos instances pour dire ce qui se
passe au sein de l'établissements ainsi
que l'implication que vous pourriez
avoir avec les services académiques des
formations et d'orientation pour qu'il y
ait une mise en cohérence des formations
et une information aussi au niveau des
parents d'élèves je suis par le passé
une présidente de fédération de parents
d'élèves et cadre de santé également et
j'ai eu justement à contribuer à
l'information des parents et de mettre
en évidence les difficultés il y avait
un salon qui se faisait à l'époque au
cwtc le salon de l'étudiant et il y
avait justement un certain nombre de de
vos collègues je parle pour ce qui
concerne la Guadeloupe en tout cas et
monsieur le Président qui proposait un
certain nombre de formations déjà au
niveau local y compris
l'instruig donc maintenant qu'il y a
difficultés y compris avec les données
démographiques que nous avons quel
impact et quels sont auront les
conséquences alors Monsieur la
Martinique on a plus ou moins la plus ou
moins évoquée mais c'est ce sont des
vrais sujets donc avec les collectivités
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez contribuer à
mettre en œuvre pour interpeler
peut-être davantage et
enfin je dirais que maintenant qu'on est
tous conscients des problématiques liées
au défi démocrates graphique pardon
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez conseiller
aussi parce que bon vous êtes là en tant
que champ consulaires mais il y a aussi
des autres les autres chambres donc
comment collectivement nous pourrons
faire en sorte que ces données soient
prises en compte pour permettre les
jeunes restent sur nos territoires qui
sont informés bien formés et que les
propositions d'emploi sont en cohérence
avec les désirs en tout cas faire mettre
en place
le monde et l'offre en quelque sorte
voilà je vous remercie
je sais pas si madame la sénatrice
puisque je suis le ressentissement de la
Guadeloupe je vais me permettre de vous
répondre et je voudrais avant tout vous
dire une chose qui est importante
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs c'est
que avec les parlementaires de façon
générale aussi bien sénateurs que
débuter nous avons des échanges
récurrents constants sur des sujets qui
nous préoccupent et on a une bonne
écoute c'est pas pour vous faire plaisir
que je dis ça c'est juste parce que on
le constate que lorsque nous prenons la
tâche de nos parlementaires on a une
écoute pour essayer de comprendre
quelles sont les difficultés que nous
avons notamment lorsque vous êtes amené
à voter pour septembre de loi
qui vont s'appliquer sur nos territoires
madame la sénatrice vous posez un
problème fondamental qui nous préoccupe
qui nous préoccupe depuis longtemps en
fin de compte vous posez une question
centrale comment on fait pour adapter
les formations des jeunes avec la
demande des entreprises
c'est triste pour nous de voir qu'un
moment donné nous sommes obligés de
dépasser nos frontières avec un surcoût
qui est considérable on recherche des
personnes pour travailler dans les
entreprises se faisant
essayer de les draguer là où elles sont
pour qu'elle puisse franchir un espace
maritime c'est-à-dire être très loin
pour venir travailler dans les
entreprises
avec tous les problèmes que ça peut
avoir le logement les loisement des
familles de faits qui doivent rentrer
etc alors qu'on aurait préféré de loin
trouver la ressource
le plus proche de l'entreprise pour
éviter ces longs déplacements et ces
problèmes liés finalement à la vie de
famille que ce soit la maison ou autre
moi je pense qu'il faut si on veut
arriver à cela
malheureusement on peut pas obliger à la
choisir
une un cursus mais il faudrait au moins
qu'il soit en capacité de mesurer
lorsqu'il choisit
quels seront ses capacités d'emploi
proche
de là où il habite parce que au final il
peut se soustraire à ça il peut très
bien faire quelque chose en sachant
qu'il va quitter le territoire c'est pas
le débat mais moi je vois avec grande je
vois saccentuer le fait que les chefs
d'entreprise ont des demandes d'emploi
insatisfaite et qu'on a un taux de
chômage très élevé c'est quand même très
compliqué ça pose un problème de
compétitivité des entreprises beaucoup
de personnes me disent avoir des
capacités de production qui ne sont
fermées fautes de personnes pour pouvoir
les faire fonctionner
et en même temps on a un taux de chômage
qui est très élevé et vous avez remarqué
que compte tenu de ce taux de chômage
très élevé récemment on a fait une
distinction entre le chômage outre-mer
et le chômage en métropole pour être un
petit peu plus généreux compte tenu du
niveau de chômage donc ça veut bien dire
que
en gros on constate cette difficulté et
pour autant on n'a pas trouvé les bonnes
réponses mais il faut qu'on s'y attelle
c'est un sujet à mon avis majeur
oui excusez-moi qu'en pensez-vous du
fait que la Région Guadeloupe paye
autant pour que certaines de nos
étudiants par exemple au Canada et alors
que sur le territoire est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas justement avec ce qui a été
proposé juste avant que
de la part de notre rapporteur madame
Jacques
ainsi que de monsieur le Président de la
CCI de Martinique donc il y a déjà cette
chambre de formation qui est de plus en
plus sont proposés par les Chambres de
commerce mais aussi par l'université
mais est-ce qu'il faut qu'on continue
sur un modèle actuel est-ce qu'il ne
faut pas qu'on se remette nous-même en
cause merci
je te laisse répondre
ça concernait les formations en
Guadeloupe enfin par la Guadeloupe au
Canada non je crois qu'on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas restreindre le champ du
possible aux étudiants ils ont envie
d'aller au Canada il faut leur permettre
d'y aller ou simplement que des
formations proposées sont en adéquation
avec les besoins du territoire et je
reviens à ce que je dis depuis longtemps
il faut un projet territoire
co-construit nous étions prévision des
emplois des compétences qui permettra
aux jeunes de de faire des choix en
conscience j'ai été président de la Dom
pendant six ans et je rencontrais de
nombreux jeunes
ultramarins qui choisissaient des
formations un peu au petit bonheur la
chance
sans véritable projet de vie au projet
professionnel ça doit pas rester
sympathique ils y allait et contre les
interrogés disaient mais si vous m'aviez
dit que nous avions des besoins
en soudeur parce que je suis sûr de
revenir à Martinique et comme personne
ne me l'a dit j'ai choisi la
scaphandrier par exemple
je crois qu'il faut il faut que chacun
soit à suivre sa part de responsabilités
la partie de l'orientation aujourd'hui
une compétence régionale et territoriale
il y a un niveau national puis il y a
une compétence au niveau régional et
peut-être que là aussi il faut que les
acteurs politiques se rapprochent plus
de des acteurs de terrain pour exercer
au mieux cette compétence en matière de
d'orientation c'est aujourd'hui une
compétence de la collectivité de
Martinique comme celle du conseil
régional de Guadeloupe voilà
messieurs je vous propose de de conclure
cette audition déjà vous remercier à mon
tour après Micheline de la qualité des
échanges et des réflexions que vous avez
bien voulu mener et qui n'ont fait que
confirmer tout l'intérêt que porte la
délégation à vous entendre sur ce sujet
et je pense que c'est c'est très
instructif en ce qui me concerne j'en ai
jamais douté parce que sur mon
territoire j'ai associé à un moment
donné la Chambre Consulaire justement
aux travaux d'élaboration d'un schéma
développement stratégique parce qu'il me
semblait naturel d'avoir les chefs
d'entreprise autour de la table après il
se posent des questions de signatures
d'investissement celui qui signe décide
enfin voilà et tel que sont fait les
contrats mais je pense que
l'intelligence collective permet parfois
de dépasser des formes réglementaires
qu'il ne permettent pas normalement de
vous associer et tout ça malheureusement
effectivement il faut passer par un
cadre parfois réglementaire pour vous
faire rentrer dans un processus qui me
paraît indispensable en termes de
d'adhésion en tout cas merci de la
qualité des échanges vous redire combien
nous sommes preneurs de peut monter des
questionnaires qui vous ont été adressés
afin de nourrir notre réflexion ce qui
vous permettra de revenir peut-être plus
dans le détail sur des éléments que vous
n'auriez pas pu développer pendant cette
audition en tout cas merci beaucoup du
temps que vous avez bien voulu nous
consacrer et je conclus cette cette
audition bonne fin de journée à tous et
à tous Merci à vous merci merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup